[Music]
it's rickety er what is this Rick it
looks like some sort of crazy video game
about us or something such as a video
game Morty
it's a virtual reality game I sold our
likenesses to some video game publisher
for a lot of money Morty and they made
it made a whole virtual reality game and
it's gonna it's got all kinds of great
things about it Morty I don't understand
Rick I mean look I don't know if I like
this you know I don't care if you like
it Morty because it's a VR game it's
it's the hottest new trend Morty it's
the hottest new future of entertainment
Morty yeah I don't know what look at
these features Morty
it doesn't get much better than this 40
well at least this part looks kind of
fun I guess look a look at those guys
explode like what else can what else do
you actually do in this game you might
be asking yourself what else does this
game have to offer
well we it's got one of these things in
it and you can do this gimmick Rick I
mean who's gonna play this you're gonna
play this Morty oh my god you killed it
I mean me
you'll never understand its majesty PR
for everyone everyone with the Box on
their face Morty one day you'll
understand more teens trading money here
see our land it's raining money haha
[Music]